Okay, so we've related our attendees to festivals. So
here we see the Johnny Concerts going in the Cloudstock,
which is very cool. so in theory if I click
this, I should be able to see everyone is going.
>> You should see Johnny and Missy.
>> Right cool. I think I'm really starting to get to know Johnny and Missy.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Okay
And it's not a field, it's this other, so fields are up here. Festival name and
all that. But this is something different, and
it's just a list of all these attendees.
>> So that's what came up at the final
step of the Field Creation Wizard. That was adding
this related list, which is just a list of
related records Onto the page layout for the festival.
>> Okay. Okay, so great. We have our
two attendees, who bought some number of tickets
I assume. But it still, I mean, of
course, it still says tickets sold as zero. There's
no way it would have known. ideally, I don't,
you know, I don't like that. What can we?
>> Well there is a way that it would have known.
And so it's really great that we can create some automated calculated
fields in Salesforce. So, we've kind of brushed upon the different
data types, but we haven't talked about roll-up summaries or formula fields.
>> Okay.
>> And so, with a roll-up summary, you're able to summarize information
about related records.
>> Okay.
>> And so, let's create a roll-up summary, based off of the attendees
to show how many tickets have been sold in total at the concert.
>> Okay. And, can we do that? I'd actually,
I don't like how we did this. I would
rather keep track of the VIP tickets sold, and
the general admission tickets sold separately. Can we do that?
>> We can. We can just create a filter on the summary, so.
>> Alright.
>> Super easy. So again, let's just go to the Quick Access menu.
And create a new field.
>> Okay, we've got a new field. And you
said roll up summary, but it is grayed out, Sam.
>> So this comes back to me just skipping through, choosing lookup over
master detail. you can only create your roll up summary when the relationship
is through a master detail relationship. And since we created a lookup, we're
not able to do rollup summaries. But thankfully, we can change it now
that we've related all of our attendees
to a festival into a master detail relationship.
So let's go back really quickly to the
attendee fields, and we can just change that.
>> Okay. Sounds good.